um
yeah hmm
um
oh
very not terrible yeah
um
uh
you think
yes
okay
um
okay
um
especially
um
okay
no no we're talking
them
um
straight to the basement
now
right
um
thank you
and
okay
okay
oh she's not at home
uh
ready
is
oh upstairs
right because they're gonna be in shape
on saturday
okay
is
story
is
um
oh
okay
from anywhere
charlie and i were
stood there
what's up
no you're on your own
you guys
good morning everyone busy time in the
capitol
this week we are doing the budget
yesterday i was very proud of the vote
that we had
on the floor of the house you've heard
me say again and again
that our budget is a statement of our
national values
what is important to us as a nation uh
should be
uh prioritized in our budget i commend
the chair
of the budget committee mr yarmouth and
the members of the committee for the
great work that they did bringing it to
the floor
and mr um don baier the chair of the
joint economic committee for his
work in the debate yesterday as well i'm
very proud of the vote
remember what we do
here is always to honor our oath of
office to support and defend the
constitution of the united states
and that constitution has as its
preamble
our guidance for a budget we the people
of the united states in order to form a
more perfect union establish justice
ensure domestic tranquility
provide for the common defense promote
the general welfare
and secure the blessings of liberty for
ourselves and for our posterity
do ordain establish this constitution so
it's about the constitution
and the liberties and the uh form of
government that it contains
but it's also our value statement so i'm
very pleased that it passed a budget
resolution
we passed a budget resolution that paves
the way
for the passage of landmark coronavirus
legislation that will save
lives and livelihoods we hope that the
republicans will join us in support
of we would prefer that
but we need to have the leverage to
proceed whether they
do or not we need to act
now because it's urgent and americans
cannot any afford any further delay
our committees now will continue to work
when the bill
contacts they'll that will be all well
as soon as the senate finishes
their work and then we pass on what they
do so hopefully that's the next 48 hours
uh then we can uh signal that we're
ready to uh mark up the bills we can
file the bills our committee
will work on the tax as i said so that
the biden
relief package will put money we're
putting money in people's pockets
vaccines and vaccinations and people's
arms
children in school workers
and to work and and speaking of
back to work also this week i'm very
pleased with the legislation
the national apprenticeship act of 2021.
uh as soon as um
we'll be debating that and voting on it
uh tomorrow
but that is very important legislation
for us to have
training for the the um workforce
development piece
of anything we do is very important as
we prepare
to go beyond this rescue package which
is what this bill
the bill i'm talking about now and then
to the recovery bill
recovery bill will be about many other
things
including infrastructure and workforce
development
is very important there in preparation
for that this apprenticeship
legislation is very important so i
commend bobby scott the chair of the
education and labor committee
for his ongoing work we passed this last
year but it
and it had bipartisan support we hope it
will again
uh tomorrow
as you know sadly this week the congress
recognized the service and sacrifice
of brian cisnick who died following uh
the terrorist mob insurrection on
january 6.
he passed on the 7th the next day we had
that lying in ceremony in the capitol
and what was so important about it
of course we paid our respects and
sympathies to his family
who spoke so lovingly and beautifully
about him
but also to see the connection
among our capitol police and how they
mourned
the loss of their colleague indeed
officer signet is a martyr
for democracy that was martyrdom that he
suffered as well
as the other uh who passed uh
officer lieberman at
leaven good and smith
and we will be honoring them
appropriately at some point when it is
uh sometime soon but right now
when it came to danger in the capital
officer ziznik
and the capitol police whom we are
enormously grateful
enormously grateful put themselves
between
us and the violence saving lives
and defending democracy indeed officer
cisnick was
again a martyr for democracy his service
and that of other heroes
in uniform some of them of the
metropolitan police of the district of
columbia
um bring luster to our constitution as i
said yesterday
and to our democracy
so very very sad to do the people's work
it is essential
to keep the people safe and to keep this
house safe
for our members our staff the custodians
who
custodial staff who make all of this
possible
for those of you who cover it in the
press for our visitors hopefully soon
we'll have some again
after covid and i want to salute the um
general honore for his work in reviewing
the security
here well i tas uh i was honored that he
accepted the charge uh to study how we
keep members safe here as they
do their jobs in washington in the
capitol
as they do their jobs in their districts
and their travel
to and fro again
the security posture of the capital
complex
and that includes the house office
buildings this will run until march 15th
one of the
proposals that he made that we've
already have
some good news on is that it was clear
that many that the capitol police have
been severely affected by covid
separate and apart from everything else
that's going on like the rest of the
country they have been severely affected
by
covid and he recommended
that we vaccinate the capitol police and
now with the cooperation of the
biden administration uh we were able to
uh to do that and i thank the acting
police chief for her
statement that she put out this morning
again uh we have the threat from within
as you are all well aware
some members refuse to comply with
security protocols
to keep members staff police officers
everyone including all of you safe
which is why we are passing a rule
mandating fines for non-compliance in
that regard you're aware of that i'm
sure
also in terms of acknowledging the
threat i remain profoundly
concerned about house republicans
leadership acceptance
of extreme conspiracy theorists
particularly disturbing their eagerness
to reward a kunan
adherent a 9 11 truther a harasser of
child
survivors of school shootings and a
value to give them
value committee positions including
who could imagine they would put such a
person
on the education committee today and the
house will vote to remove
represent green from her seat on
education and labor and the budget
committees
you're that's just so unfortunate you
would think
that the republican leadership in the
congress would have some
sense of responsibility to this
institution
as they did when they did not see
representative king of iowa uh two years
ago
for some reason they have chosen not to
go down that path
even though we gave mr hoyer gave the
leader
mccarthy sufficient notice that this was
a path we would follow
again i'm legislating on terms of the
budget in terms of the
apprenticeship program in terms of
putting together
our legislation for a commission similar
to 9 11 commission
uh i'm very pleased that uh others and
i commended the wasserman schultz for
taking the lead on honoring our oath
of office to uphold the protect the
constitution but not only that
to uphold the steer standard for the
house of representatives that respects
the institution in which we
serve and does no harm to it
institutionally or to our members staff
visitors personally with that i'd be
pleased to take any questions
let me see let me
question from one see the pool reporters
who's unable to be here today so if i
could
they do go together um first just
looking up ahead to the impeachment
trial
was that this announcement that you're
going to have two questions yes
is that right with all the rest
um looking ahead to the impeachment
child next week it will be
one month since the attack on the
capital the former president
is long gone there are plenty of people
who say
why bother why go through this entire
exercise
what do you say to them well i
appreciate that question because
uh it seems to me that the answer is
self-evident again
we're here to support and defend the
constitution of the united states
of the world witnessed the incitement
that the president caused to incite a
insurrection against our government
against our capital against members of
congress
with the use of force and violence so
we for us to why bother
why bother ask our founders
why bother ask those who wrote the
constitution
ask abraham lincoln ask anyone
who cares about our democracy
why we are bothering you cannot
go forward until you have justice and
what did we say about the
preamble to the constitution uh didn't
we
say it started out uh with justice
we the people of the united states in
order to form a
more perfect union establish
justice you've heard me say again and
again
paul vi said if you want peace work for
justice
martin luther king
peace is not just the absence of
dissension
it is the presence of justice so we will
honor the constitution by establishing
justice and again we can do a couple of
things at once
we are moving with our legislation uh to
pass the
biden administration biden harris
administration
covet package uh the uh
people the whole world were witnesses
to this as i said before so we'll see i
have no idea
how the managers will proceed
i saw their brief when you saw their
brief
i'm so proud of the dignity with which
they have brought
to enabling us to honor our constitution
if we were not to follow up with this we
might as well remove
any penalty from the constitution of
impeachment
just take it out but our founders they
they knew about two things and
we keep hearing this again and again
they wanted
they were fearful of a demagogue and
they were fearful of a demagogue and a
mob
and that's exactly what descended the
effect of that is exactly what defended
on the constitution
but i want the public to know that there
is no
opportunity cost in our defending the
constitution
in fact it is an enhancement for us to
do our work in a way
uh that is respectful of the
institutions in which we serve the
constitution
which we take an oath uh to uh uh to
protect and defend
the other question our colleague from
the um la times had asked
um that the house managers are walking
into a trial where all signs
point to acquittal um they don't know
that
they don't know that they don't know
that they haven't heard the case
they don't have the case but they the uh
and the and the court of the senate they
will make their case
in the court of public opinion they will
make their case
and for history and posterity as our
colleague as our founder said
uh to ourselves and our posterity uh
they will make the case
uh but uh i have great confidence in
them and we'll see
we'll see if it's gonna be a senate of
courage
or look cowardice
but you know what we have why don't we
just wait and let them make their case
uh i don't want i they have been very so
we say
silent hard-working
brilliant in terms of what we saw in the
brief
not only wise but you might appreciate
well written and no spelling mistakes of
the united states
so again i'm not here to to talk about
that
because they are going to be there to
present the case
and we don't have to defend why it is
necessary
and we don't have to uh uh
talk about who's going to be there or
not because we just don't know
they know and they will present it when
when they do yes sir i was wondering
what you thought of um
the republican senator's plan they went
to the white house this week to meet
with the president
um and and how much the plan is at 1.9
joe biden has indicated he wants to stay
there is that where you think it'll end
up
well the is the joe biden has presented
a plan
that meets the needs of the american
people this is very important because
we have been you see i want to read this
to you because i think this is very
important for people to know we'll get
around 450 000 people who have died
before you know it's sad to say and
hopefully we don't achieve it
but we're on a path to a half a million
people
dying from covet
and that is because of a complete
failure on the part
of the trump administration but don't
take it from me
oh this is what the gao and our 346
page government accountability document
said it said almost 90 percent
27 of 31 of the gao's recommendations
from june september and november remain
unimplemented as of january 15th
less than a week before trump led office
gop remains deeply troubled that the
agencies have not
acted on recommendations to more fully
address
official gaps in the medical supply
chain and the list goes on
we want to save lives and save
livelihoods
it's going to cost some money to do so
but it is a good investment and don't
take it from us whether you're talking
about the chairman of the fed the
secretary of the treasury
uh mark zandy other economists have said
even the governor of west virginia has
said
go big rather than go small
and and that's what we have to do it is
a reasonable
plan it meets the needs it is not
excessive it is coronavirus centric
it is in a timely fashion and that's
where we have to go
if we are going to again put vaccine in
people's arms
children in school money in people's
pockets
and workers back in their jobs so it's a
it's pretty exciting what he's put there
and what we did at the end of december
plus this is approximately what we have
been
advocating in the heroes act all along
3.2 this
comes up to nearly three uh trillion
dollars
but that's what benisa for the
republican senators to come in at 600
billion
one-third well what is it are we going
to feed fewer children
are we going to inoculate fewer people
are we going to
how how do you cut that i think they
have not respected our heroes by
supporting state and local government
these are the people who are on the
first line whether it's health care
workers
police and fire first responders of any
kind
sanitation transportation food workers
our teachers our teachers our teachers
our schools we have to invest
in safely be turning our children to
school so
again uh
i i just don't see how you have to make
those choices about
who you cut out when you decide to cut
the funding uh in in the package yes you
have back
speaker um given some of the events uh
in russia
and burma this week curious if you
believe that the house will move forward
with any sort of response sanctions
anything like that well we look
to the leadership of our new president
on that score i myself have been
a supporter of sanctions of burma at the
time
going way back i still call it burma as
a matter of fact
and then uh and of course uh to really
enforce the sanctions
on russia in a way that really reaches
uh the shall we say enablers
of putin but again we'll take our lead
uh from the president because
uh he's made his voice clear to putin
and he said
i made a statement about miramar and so
a miramar they said they were arresting
her for importing
illegal radios and in uh russia they
uh arrested naman for um not reporting
to his
probation officer or something like that
so again it's an interesting time
uh to see demagoguery around the
world and we have to prevent it from
happening in our country yes sir
good morning madam speaker thank you on
the budget reconciliation package
obviously there are a lot of democratic
policy priorities that they'd like to
put in this
uh there's hearing going on right now
about the minimum wage with marty walsh
if some of those things like the minimum
wage don't wind up in the bill
because you know you could work through
this process you have to get the votes
what's that what's the message to folks
who are thinking this was our chance to
get these things done
it doesn't mean it won't happen just
because they won't happen
there uh as you know uh in many ways
we're at the mercy
of the senate in terms of the byrd rule
and again
um the parliamentarian of the senate
is going to make some determinations we
had hoped she would make them by now
but until we have our bill which we now
have
uh we don't have those determinations
from her
but it's it this there's so much in the
package that has to be
done right now and we'll do the best we
can
do you have concern though that some who
said okay the democrats are going to
have the house they're going to have the
senate they're going to have the white
house
and you say you know discipline's not in
this bill doesn't mean it doesn't get
done
but they will be disappointed and have
you responded and say look you know
we're thinking
are introducing the minimum wage that's
a very high priority for us
but we can't but and we hope that we can
get it
uh in reconciliation i'm a veteran of
reconciliation bills over time and i
know the
i know the uh shall we say the struggle
that it frequently is to have everything
comply
in a way that meets the standards of the
senate in terms of the bird rule
we in the house think of it sort of a
house of lords attitude why don't we
just
why don't we just pass what we can pass
without having it being determined uh by
one person as to what can be contained
in there
just put it on there vote it up or vote
it down but in any event
we have we're very proud of the
legislation and and
uh again it's not the last bill we'll
pass this is the recovery
this is the rescue package this is the
rescue pack we must
pass this bill to crush the virus
to save the lives and livelihoods of the
american people
to put children back in school and
people back to work
that is its purpose we want to do it in
a way
that is fair uh that that
addresses the disparities that existed
do you know in the native american
community
two times as many people percentage-wise
have died
than whites it it the disparity in the
asian ameri the
the um african-american community and in
the hispanic community is
sinful so as we do this bill we want to
do so in a way
that is fair and equitable and continue
to do testing etc
distribution of the virus but keeping a
record
of how this has been distributed then
then hopefully we can get to a place
where this bill will be a force
for fairness rather than
ossifying some of the unfairness that
has gone before
then we have the the other the next bill
will be
this is rescue that's recovery and we're
already
working uh with some of the provisions
that we would have
in a recovery act we're legislators
that's why we're here that's
what we do and so we're always getting
ready for the next
legislation build back better for the
people these were
some of what we talked about joe biden
said help is on the way
and the recovery package uh with lower
health care costs and bigger paychecks
for the people is what we need to do so
just because something might not be in
one bill
uh and and we don't accept that yet but
if it isn't
uh we have other places to do it in fact
uh
i wish we were talking about a living
wage but fifteen dollars an hour
is an important improvement uh over that
i just had time for one more question
i'm just curious as
far as the impeachment trial is
concerned uh
senator graham said that if the
democrats call
any witness that they'll be prepared the
republicans will be prepared to call in
the fbi and quote
tell us about people who pre-planned
this attack and what happened with the
security
footprint at the capitol what's your
response to that your question is a
waste of time
yes are you worried at all about the
president that it would say
no moving not at all no no if any of our
members threaten the
safety of other members we'd be the
first ones to take them off a book
committee
that's it thank you are you willing to
compromise on the eligibility for
stimulus payment